Next up, incoherent
Lands' End vulture Sarah Palin,
-uh... the Ala...
-(laughter)
the Alaskan rodeo cyborg came
roaring back into the spotlight
to jump on the Trump wagon.
Here she is endorsing him
back in January.
Looking around at all of you,
you hard-working Iowa families,
you farm families, and...
teachers and teamsters
and... cops and cooks,
you rock and rollers,
and holy rollers...
you with the hands
that rock the cradle...
(laughter, shouting)
Total... total courtesy smile
for that.
(like Palin): To all you
hands that rock the cradle
and girl interrupteds
and single white females
and Jennifer 8,
this is for all
the Rosemary's babies
and the Air Buds
and the big trouble
in Little Chinas
-(cheering, applause)
-and Fridays and Next Fridays,
and especially all you workin'
hard down at the road house
by point break.
This campaign
will never die hard!
(laughter, applause, cheering)
Comedians,
where is Sarah Palin now?
-April. -I don't know,
probably becoming a grandmother
for, like, the ninth time.
Bristol hates condoms!
All right, points. Points.
Uh... up to her tits in pills.
-(laughter)
-Points.
Sarah Pillin. Ramon.
Based off of her sweater,
Jo-Ann Fabrics.
-Yes, points.
-(laughter, whooping, applause)
No.
That's not a...
I'll tell you exactly
what happened.
A disco ball got loose
in Anchorage
and she hunted it
and skinned it.
-(laughter)
-That is what happened.
-I used every part
of the disco ball. -Every part!